consumer groups are urging the federal
government to investigate whether
advertisers are taking unfair advantage
of young kids using apps this comes
after a new study found that 95% of the
most downloaded apps for kids 5 and
under target them with ads and a Warner
shows us the growing concern and a good
morning good morning researchers at the
University of Michigan spent hundreds of
hours playing 135 different games
targeting young children for the study
they found advertising across the board
not just in video games but also in apps
marketed as educational what's the best
for in the Montague household using apps
is a part of everyday life for
four-year-old Elliot and seven-year-old
Ethan the first thing in the morning
when they wake up is they want to use
their their tablet time for the day but
what some parents don't realize is how
many of their kids interactive games are
littered with ads University of Michigan
assistant professor dr. Jenny Radetzky
there's a bit of a Wild West right now
in terms of the children's app space
where dusky is the senior author of a
new study which looked at more than a
hundred of the most downloaded apps on
google play aimed at children five years
and under researchers found those apps
contained a variety of ads including
pop-ups in-app purchases and videos that
interrupted play some of the ads were
classified as manipulative deceptive and
disruptive with exposure to ads
sometimes even surpassing time spent
playing the games so there might be a
little bouncing present or a sparkling
snowman and if you click on that as you
would if you were a five-year-old an app
ad would often show up it absolutely has
the intent that the advertisers want
like the kids will often come and say I
want to download this game and want this
game I want to try it out the study also
found that free apps which may be more
often downloaded and played by
lower-income children had a
significantly higher prevalence of
advertising in a statement Google stood
by its current policies saying play apps
primarily directed to children must
follow more stringent requirements
including content and add restrictions
additionally Google Play discloses
whether an app has advertising or in-app
purchases so parents can make informed
decisions I think the one thing I'd
spend more attention on is personally
monitoring their tablet time and not
just letting them do it alone well the
researchers say apps for kids need
greater government regulation the maker
of one of the apps mentioned in the
study talking tom told us they're
responding to feedback that some of
their games ads could be interpreted as
misleading and are taking immediate
action to make sure ads are clearly
marked as such so my stomach just
dropped Anna has a mom kids play on
these games alone unmonitored what else
can parents be doing aside for
monitoring their yeah well that's kind
of what the senior author is saying
about the study is look if you're a
parent you need to watch the apps and
watch to see what your kids are seeing
picking up on look for these ads but if
you look at some of them like one of
them looks like a little glowing
birthday cake it's kind of hard to tell
they look innocent and the you I read
the reviews and I say okay you can play
this game I never once thought that they
would be targeted at 6 years old it's
crazy
what's monetizing the games right it's a
way to make more money because the kids
get into the game or just like an adult
game you get into the game you want to
play some more and they're like well if
you buy this then you play more you get
a new character whatever it is
well now parents have been warned well
in the app stores can make it bright
clear and obvious that the kids are
going to be asked to make in-app
purchases sometimes it's in tiny little
letters hard to see without a magnifying
glass right and the parents have to have
time to pay attention to all that yeah
yeah never and I will do that but we
will be thanks to you Anna